Anyway, this video Jan Bökemann Jan Böckermann
Ciao are
doing the experimental mode
again I don't really have any ID about
the crew
no specific knowledge
s way is going for rock beyone
five line wird i don't really now
anything about them
trying for this  is a verration
i think this is this is sossend
age 6 maybe
ja more sorry white has a very very
decent compensation
okay
sind
strange wird
Trading stuff cannot be that really
Check
okay now not doing that '
s
Age 2
okay okay Trade
Biscuit I get  the sea and queensy fire for
Poster accounte play ja das ist true bei der
sind die 5 now
the color snow BITV
die five Hanks he protected
not at all
but this is so great I don't really
believe it the point
probly takes to the six
in the end
oh wow
biscuit scolded the thre 5 okay now a
little bit okay
definitely use the whistle check
okay that's
the last one
from thinking FTX
yeah okay a little bit tricky I really over
look that deformers hanging it probly
wasn't bad yeah but the computer  ist
justing am winning all along here is
completelay you takes every every
material giving to him and wins Rook A5
for the wind okay
TX enough Justin here
and Black Wings ja okay das the look the
scary to the human eye
never there is no Mia
okay das  ist
hanging mit check this was problem
I like black
it's Nothing nothing special the compast
like my zero point six zero from seven
okay